I would always try to start with the
services instead of a product most
people who start with a product end up
getting screwed because the margins suck
on most products unless you go scale
meaning if you're going to sell t-shirts
selling five t-shirts there's no margin
in it right you can do print on demand
but there's no margin in it so you get
the scale then you have to buy 10 000
t-shirts and people go and do this they
buy a thousand t-shirts ten thousand
t-shirts and then you sell four and the
rest sit in your mom's garage self-love
comes from doing difficult things so the
more that you say yes to the hard things
right like even in me inviting people up
to join on stage that's scary for some
people every time you come across
something scary and you don't do it you
remind yourself you start to teach
yourself that you do not do scary things
would you go in the business with
someone who cheats in their relationship
no any explanation
having a y is super critical like the
thing that gets me going every day is
pretty why I do what I do how to live in
a moment oh okay that's a good question
Marion question here we go how do you
come up a price for your first job so
there are a couple things involved one
yeah let's go with that focusing on
what's the end result of that project
like if it if you're a freelancer
obviously what are you gonna do are you
just gonna redesign a photo versus
redesigning the whole website right so
that's number one number two looking
identifying a little bit the
competitions what type of price points
because you have to be realistic right
what type of price points uh competition
is charging for that and then us going
back and reverse engineering that into
how can we make the end result even more
valuable for uh the person so there is a
combination of those couple of things
right like first if you look at the
competition of course you're trying to
be somewhere in the middle especially if
you're if you're coming up for the job
most likely you're going to be a
beginner
if you're coming up with a job uh price
point you're at the beginning stage of
your freelancing part right or contact
you whatever it says so if you look at
the competition and then you look at
what what kind of value you can bring at
the end of the project
figure out ways of how you can improve
that and then you come up with the price
It's a combination of those two things
assuming the same uh line of thinking
with Mary in terms of hey you're a
freelancer you have a service I would
always try to start with the services of
a product most people who start with a
product end up getting screwed because
the margins suck on most products unless
you go scale meaning if you're going to
sell t-shirts selling five t-shirts
there's no margin in it right you can do
print on demand but there's no margin in
it so you get the scale then you have to
buy 10 000 t-shirts and people go and do
this they buy a thousand t-shirts ten
thousand t-shirts and then Yourself four
and the rested in your mom's garage
right and so it's almost never the best
idea to start with a product you start
with the service so you're trading your
time for money at the beginning ideally
finding something that you can uh
make a good margin off of your time
right and what I like to do with the
entrepreneurs that I invest in who
started and we've done this now
five times
mid six figure businesses uh from
scratch
and the starting point that I like to
get in at is what can you sell for two
thousand dollars a month 2K a month is a
starting point
the first project is usually free
because it's a service so you're not out
of pocket any it's time but you're not
in a pocket any hard cost expenses so
the first project should be free
over deliver go talk to 50 to 100
potential clients and over deliver right
and do the first thing for free doesn't
mean you do everything for free but you
do the first one for free to give them
some something extraordinary so whether
you're doing copywriting or thumbnail
design or Instagram reels or chat GPT
prompts or whatever the thing is that
you sell coaching Consulting the first
one you do for free to build up your
skill set to build up the reputation to
over deliver like crazy so that they
want to continue to work with you and
then ongoing I'd be looking at how do
you do at least a two thousand dollar a
month package right you get five people
at 2K a month you're a 10K a month
that's a kick-ass business for a lot of
people right so what can you sell for
two can months so let me break it down
for how we've done it with
um let's say Zach right Zach was on
yesterday who's the newest person I
started helping
was on track for six figures within uh
three weeks of working together so
here's what he did he made a list of all
the people that he wanted to talk to all
the people who could be potential ideal
fits right like don't Target people who
don't have money because they can't pay
you ultimately yes ultimately your big
mission I want to serve everybody I want
to help the world but you can't start
with people who don't have money because
otherwise you don't make any money right
so in the service based business Zach
made a list of all the people who could
be potential ideal clients for him okay
for YouTube consultant
next he reached out and gave them free
advice I got three ideas to help you
really blow up your YouTube channel
here's what I'd recommend that you do he
did email he did LinkedIn messages he
did Loom videos to send people he did
Instagram DMS he did whatever he can
find on the on the people of Ideal
clients right so how do you build a
six-figure business in three weeks okay
they find what he says interesting then
they hop on a call free a free call and
the call would be half an hour to an
hour free giving them advice guidance
counsel answering their questions on how
to do well on YouTube or just saying
he's selling but then after that it's
two thousand dollars a month
right minimum so right now
the packages would be between 2K and the
high end would be 10K a month I'm trying
to think is anybody over
to the highest time it's like 10 11 12K
something like that but people start off
with 2K a month right and so you can go
free
you give them insane value
you're not asking for permission just
send it to them here's free work not hey
can I send you some free work no you
just send it to them just send it to
them for free
hop on a call free and then after that
call it's 2K a month what could you
offer that is 2K a month and get five
clients at 2K a month
you have a 10K a month business
that happened in three weeks for Zach
would you go into business with someone
who cheats in their relationship wow
what a question okay no
that has to do with you as a person
so uh it depends on the principles you
know it's it's very it's a tough
question it is but um
oh man I would say in my personal
opinion I I wouldn't because it's not
part of my principles but uh hey yeah
that's just my opinion would you go in
the business with someone who cheats in
their relationship no
that's it any any explanation
because they may cheat because they may
cheat on YouTube okay so I
I would say
probably not
it would be a strike it would be a big
strike against but I also believe in
Redemption
you know like I think it'd be like a 90
no but what I believe in Redemption and
so what I I like to know the context
like what happened what happened that
led to them cheating are they sorry for
it have they learned from their last
like we've all screwed up and we've all
made mistakes in the past right uh if
you're interviewing for a job interview
or your clients like there's always
something that we've done in the past
that
um that we're not proud of but have you
have you grown someone and have you
learned from it and maybe yes they have
uh maybe they haven't you know if they
haven't then it's an easy no
but uh I like to hold out the little
percentage of of redemption just in case
so Rina my answer would be 90 no but 10
maybe
they've learned something
how to live in a moment oh okay that's a
good question slow down stop what you do
what you do take a d breath in
in we're here right now this is us
living in the moment being present with
our Evan Carmichael like how I'm so
grateful that
you hit me with a surprise like do I go
live with him like yes yes
until
of course
of course and and you gave us you gave
us a live demo there that was great I
was expecting just some kind of answer
but you're like no we're gonna yeah
we're gonna demo this together let's go
deep breath in how to live in a moment
think about why you're not being present
so you're either in the past
like if you're not present here and now
you're in the past and if you're living
in the past it's usually in a really
negative way you're thinking about the
things that you [__] down you wish
you'd done actually that you should have
taken things you should have said to
somebody you live with these like I
should have and we we're constantly
living in regret of the things that we
did do or didn't do right that's living
in the past
or we're living in the future and most
of the time when we live in the future
we're not happy and excited and positive
and optimistic we're stressed we're
stressed about the thing that's coming
up we're stressed about the call that we
have to take we're stressed about the
thing that we want to sell and whether
it will work out or not we're stressed
about the bills that are coming up and
whether we can afford to pay them or not
we're just constantly stressed so
looking backwards is often regret
looking forwards is often stress and so
the power of being in the moment to
being in the presence is that a lot of
that evaporates and the easiest way to
do it for me is I catch it and you just
come back to now and just find one thing
to appreciate of what you got right now
like it's sunny
you know where's the sun look at that
it's sunny here in Arizona I get to walk
with my wife I get to talk with you guys
just focus on what we've got right now
so anytime that you see yourself going
backwards or going forwards into the
future just bringing back the present
just find one little thing I focus on my
footsteps hitting the ground I'm poking
this on my hand touching the phone I
focus on the drink touching my lips
and the more that you practice that the
more it'll start to become automatic and
second nature so you spend less time
regret in the past and stressing about
the future so we have a question from my
audience that you're going to be great
to answer this how can we change a
people please attitude and love
ourselves more
we have difficulty with that sometimes
when we have children's for example uh
we say that children's is the most
important thing in the world for us so I
think you have to put yourself in the
first place so that you can love
yourself and then be better for others
because you cannot be the best for
others if you are not the best for
yourself self-love comes from doing
difficult things so the more that you
say yes to the hard things right like
even in me inviting people up to join on
stage
that's that's scary for some people
great every time you come across
something scary and you don't do it you
remind yourself and you start to teach
yourself that you do not do scary things
and then what happens the next time
something scary comes up you're not
going to do it again and you're not
going to do it again and so the key is
if something is scary difficult hard if
you're not doing something because
somebody else's opinion is keeping you
from doing it
we have to break that pattern whether
the thing you end up doing works out or
not doesn't matter is that you were
willing to try and so when you don't
have these are really connected right
the people place an attitude and lack of
self-love are really connected because
if you don't love yourself then you need
other people's validation you're doing
things just to support other people's
view of you instead of doing it for your
own reasons
and so the more you build up your
self-love by doing difficult things the
less you care what other people think
about you
so anything that is scary that's
difficult hard you do it you try you
expect to fail at the beginning just
like you fail at everything at the
beginning but you start
and every time you do that you build up
a little more self-love so here's the
question Angela if you have the
opportunity to interview your personal
hero who would that be and why okay I
know I'm going to get a little sappy
um but it would be my mom
um my my mom
um
20 not this past November but a year ago
November
um she passed away and so that same
month that um she passed away
um she and I had scheduled we scheduled
a live together and it didn't happen and
so I regret that so much
um and you don't sometimes realize even
who your personal heroes are until it's
too late and so since she's been gone
I've learned a lot and I that is who I
wish I could
so but today um who would it be yeah I
did we're going deep on the first
question let's go Angela okay no no it's
great that's great I love it and and
what if you had to pick somebody alive
who would you pick Angela there's so
many amazing superhumans that are out
there
gosh some of
some would probably be she's certainly a
hero
um Tony Robbins all of the big names
um I wouldn't want to miss that
opportunity Oprah if you're listening
connect with uh Angela
discussing great questions to ask you I
like Angela's answer but the parents
both my parents are still alive
um they are my heroes although I don't
like I guess at some point we probably
make content there they don't they don't
want to be public
uh so I don't know maybe we filmed
something and then it only goes up in 10
years or something I don't know
um but if you're going not my parents if
I'm gonna go historical I would go
apiganini it's my favorite entrepreneur
of all time
uh if I go alive today
Angela to go for us so I'd love to have
a conversation about entrepreneurship
with Oprah which we're also trying to
make work by the way so send some
positive Oprah Vibes my way and uh
Angela too so the two people that I
would have on my list were Oprah and
Kanye okay and let me explain both of
them so Oprah mostly because I've never
heard a great interview with Oprah
talking about entrepreneurship
and she's she hasn't had a lot of
interviews lately at all but all of her
stuff has been
around her causes or her life or her
story which is all fantastic and they're
always great but there's never been one
that I saw about entrepreneurship advice
and here's like the the
richest woman of all time most
successful woman of all time and she's
never talked about entrepreneurship and
if you guys have seen it let me know
because I want to see it
um and then Kanye all honestly the same
question and Kanye might be a little too
too hot right now or might get a little
bit too too uh
much negative comments to the wrong
reasons but same thing like people sleep
on Kanye's uh entrepreneurship and
skills uh and he's never done a really
good interview most of the interviews
that people do are like they try to do
the gotcha moments right with with
people like Kanye he's like oh if
they're looking for the clips looking
for the gotcha moments where for me
would just be trying to learn so that's
what I would pick
the last couple months I've um I've
really been off like just um
off line so to speak I've had a lot
going on personally you know working on
buying this new business and just a lot
of stuff that's kept me away from doing
this stuff and you kind of feel like um
and then this training with you know for
this race and Angela and all that but um
I I don't know it's all I almost feel
like I've been derailed and I'm trying
to figure out the best way to get back
on track because as I'm growing and
developing I'm also realizing how other
things are shifting as well you know
what I mean and not sure how to have
that um like Synergy between what I'm
trying to do with you online and then
the business it almost seems like
there's been a big Divine so I'm trying
to figure out like how to put it back
together
well didn't didn't you get this business
opportunity by posting content I did but
I can't share how I got it sure that's
fine but you could you can say that hey
I posted content and I got this deal as
a result of it right yeah right
so okay so I mean you are you were on a
roll for a little bit and I remember
seeing the videos in the car and and you
know the pictures and everything and and
then what
you know when you have a pause it's a
good time for reflection what did you
not even thinking about like what not
not worry about what worked and what
didn't work but what did you enjoy
from what you were doing what did you
not enjoy
you mean before the break yeah
the interaction I was getting
I enjoyed the response I would get it
was getting from people but it was more
on the um the private personal side
dealing with you know the addiction
depression anxiety things like that and
people are just fragile in that state so
I really feel good about helping people
because I remember what I felt like
but I wasn't at that point where I
really wanted it out there publicly I'm
trying to figure out how to get to the
people and my heart bleeds for that so
that's always going to be something I do
is just my own personal mission to pay
it forward
um and I I don't have the time to spend
a lot of one-on-one now and I guess I
was really getting hung up on okay how
do I scale it how do I take what I know
what's the kind of vehicle can I
recommend to put it online to start
building and then I ran into some
technical stuff because like I'm just
not good at Tech and trying to find
somebody
um and it kind of got overwhelmed and I
think I just kind of backed off
they're maybe a little intimidated by a
not knowing what to do and B once I
start thinking about what I want to do
not knowing how to do it
so who in your circle can help you with
the tech yeah that's that's uh my small
town that's a loaded question but not
even like so what about online what
about people movement makers what about
people who are part of your community
even if it's not you know the biggest
Community yet right
I'm not sure I'm not sure who can do
what
I'm not even sure what I need to be
honest with you well okay so you know I
just started a Discord server okay so
here's what happened and I think this is
relevant um I was helping Tom will you
launch his nmt over the weekend
uh and I bought his legendary key and
and was super involved in the Discord I
didn't know anything about anything
okay his wife Lisa texted me
on Friday and I I didn't even have
enough eth in my wallet to buy it so I
had to bum it off a friend
because it takes like a week to get it
into the especially from Canada so I put
out but this is like I need to make this
happen I want to get this nft to support
Tom I don't even know what I get with
the nft I just want to support Tom
because Lisa texted me right and so I'm
going to I asked drew first he doesn't
have a liquid so I go to one of my
communities and say hey who will lend me
three East so I can buy this
and three eth is like ten thousand
dollars yeah ish right
um so that's not something that most
people I guess just have hey go for it
but
anyway somebody gave it to me lent it to
me I said how to pay her back
and then I started getting involved in a
Discord so Tom has Discord I didn't know
anything about Discord
so then we launched our own Discord and
it's a great way to connect and I'm
honestly thinking about moving a lot of
my communities even movement makers at
some point from Facebook to Discord but
here's what happened like when I got
inside Discord I was on Toms just to
give value just to give love just to
speak for Tom because sometimes when
somebody else is saying the message it
you know it's more believable
um and then somebody said hey uh I'd
love if you joined Discord I'd love to
be a part of it
so there's this one guy Jonathan
we set it up together and they gave him
his full admin rights it's like well
let's do it together
he's like I'll help I was like oh well
how about let's do it together and it's
like recruiting him to join because I
don't know any I'm asking all the Newbie
questions I don't know anything about
anything of Discord roles and the rules
and the and the badges and the upranking
it's like it's all crazy confusing to me
but this guy knows it and and he loves
the mission of what we're doing
and so it's asking for help right like
you love helping all these people we're
coming to ask you for help
but now it's asking other people for
help and recruiting them so it's not
he's not showing me how to do it this is
where this is the help you really need
he's not showing me how to do it so I
can do it
he's doing it
right
like there's a box just set up if
somebody buys one of my nfts that
verifies them so they can get in a
special club and they get a special
color when they're in my Discord I don't
know how to do that
I don't want to know how to do that he
just set it up last night for me
right so I think that's the difference
you can have you can watch like you
don't want to sit there and watch
tutorials and you don't want somebody to
show you how to edit this video and how
to do all the technical stuff you just
want somebody to actually take care of
it for you and there will be people who
who can do that who you've helped and
you've impacted I I know you've poured
so much into people not just since
starting
posting Instagram content and YouTube
content but before that there's so many
people you've poured into that there has
to be people locally and online who if
you just ask for help
and said hey I really need like if that
was your goal knowing you you know if
that was your goal
for next month it would happen
and then it unlocks a lot more fun and
creativity and time for you so it's not
as overwhelming
yeah and it was the process because I
would think about all the steps needed
done and I would start looking into one
and I'm thinking well you got to do this
first well you got to go here and then
you're like
you know and and it's I kind of held
back like
well actually I'll get to this in a
second like I I have an idea on how I
want the content to go I kind of have
that flow but it was up figuring out the
infrastructure how to get it down
through because like I have no problem
talking posting speaking like I'm not
worried about that and and I've done a
lot of that so now I'm like all right
well it's time to transition this to
more of a professional appearance and
process
and not knowing what to do
over the last probably a month the one
thing I did do was I flipped open I have
a laptop that I don't use for anything I
actually started writing because I'm
like you know I'm I'm hearing things
from all these different people and like
oh that's a good quote or all that's
that it stimulates thought so I actually
whether Nobody Does it but me I've
actually started to write it in a book
form
starting from just me and you you told
me a while ago like what were the
different steps of like well how did you
deal with the health and how did you
deal with the finances and how did you
deal with the relationships and I wasn't
even sure if I would have enough to
write and what's funny is I probably
have about 40 pages done and I haven't
even gotten to those steps yet yeah
because
it's not like about me it's more about
how it ties in that I think almost
anybody can plug themselves in and it
doesn't even have to be from a
dependency standpoint is from a
a life standpoint and I'm thinking like
the more I write I actually do feel that
creativeness coming out which is funny
because I was never a creative person
there's always a numbers person and I'm
starting to see my own quotes develop
I'm like well maybe I just need to
finish this and use this as my okay this
is my hub
and now I can pull bits and pieces for
different things and that's kind of
where my mind has been going
I don't know what your thoughts are on
that yeah it definitely works I think
um writing is a great way to do it I
think you'll also get a lot of Great
Moments just by talking to people or by
what you're doing on DMS you know that
you'll
what's great when there's interaction is
it forces you to
um stretch because you say something but
then there's a there's a bounce back
right there's like okay yeah Evan but
what about this and in that
allows you to come up with a new way of
saying it because you're right probably
but but they didn't hear it properly so
you have to see them in a different way
which then leads to a different analogy
or different example or different phrase
and when you're with somebody you'll
often come up with
different stories and examples and then
that helps feed the curriculum as well
or the thesis or the right but it
doesn't only have writing is a great way
to get it out
but your inspiration can come from
anywhere
I saw it starting as almost like a
decluttering you know it's the whole um
ADHD thing bouncing around of like you
know what just empty your head get it
out and then do what you want with it
because like I said I I'll go and I just
my mind just starts jumping and I do I
have a focus problem but
um
it
that that's just what I've been doing in
the time because I haven't been posting
but I haven't been totally wasting the
time either because I'm like well in the
end where am I sending where am I
sending people to or what I'm what's my
ultimate goal from a message standpoint
I've never been able to answer that
question
and one day I'd feel it's this the next
day it's that and not all valid all part
of a puzzle but just not the pieces have
not been lining up to where I feel I can
do anything with it
and all of your options of what you
could send people are all legit and
valid and they've worked for other
people it's just none of them feel right
yet
and and that's fine like you you won't
find out until you actually start doing
it
like it could be push people to coach
him but then like I don't want to do
one-on-one coaching anymore so it could
be pushing the people the group coaching
but maybe maybe that's not the model you
want to do either so maybe it's pushing
people to a program like you figure
they're all great models the business
model exists otherwise you wouldn't
understand it but which one's gonna fit
for you
you don't know till you do it right the
I know the one on the one-on-one is
never going to especially not with my
day-to-day life now you know my business
it's kind of blowing up which is good
but I have kids too and yeah I mean I
don't have the time to be that dedicated
to the one-on-one at least not right now
so you use it when it makes sense to
create content right when when I mean I
get not most people won't want to come
public and make a video but some will
right it's five percent of them well
that's that's content that then you're
helping one person but then other people
get the benefit from it as well
right but I think if you like think
about so you bought my nft have you
bought an entity before mine no
did you know anything about
wallets and eth and W eth and Open Seas
yeah actually
um openc was new but I've I've been
studying crypto for a few years now
playing around so yeah I understood all
that great and so you know Angela at the
beginning said I'm so jealous of Evan
because he's always the first one to do
everything
but you know okay you got anybody else
like you got to be you got to be in a
position to pull the trigger well and
you gotta
you got to decide like you didn't have
all of it figured out you knew a little
bit about crypto and you've been
studying it but you hadn't you hadn't
bought anything yet and now this became
you decided okay I'm gonna go and go off
and do it
and and you know the ADHD is uh you know
the entrepreneur's curse
but it also allows for like when you're
in something you're in it you know it's
like when you decide I need to figure
this out boom you go on you figure it
out and nothing else matters and so just
putting that attention on the right
thing so
you found a way to go buy the nft even
though you've never bought an nft before
you could have said well what do I
normally do I get overwhelmed and I
don't understand the technical and you
know that's what I always do and to
spell back nothing but
you decided this time you know what you
know what you know you know you know the
difference yeah I enjoy I I enjoy that
technical piece
which is weird because we we get we
spend the time on what we enjoy like
figuring that out like uh I'm
I'm all in on on the crypto world still
learning but because I have an interest
I'm all in editing a video I could care
less so then I'm like Ugh why bother you
know so I I understand what you're
saying like just
well and and donated videos right I mean
you don't need to edit videos just
spit fire into the camera in post but I
could also YouTube a video on on
transferring to you know
all the different things too and then
just go do it I don't have to go look
for someone ask the questions do it
figure out interview trial and error
it's like I get the info and just do it
myself yeah with that stuff I have no
desire so I can't do it
I hear you and if you just put that
intention on finding a person and then
they take care of it I mean when you
started off in saying well I want my
videos to be more professional you don't
you don't need to
you know I'm gonna film
a bunch of videos tomorrow
from my car
I'm gonna take your phone and film
what's actually funny I'm sitting in my
office and my employee um I have a power
outage in the neighborhood which is why
I'm in the dark I have no internet no
lights like I'm sitting by a window and
and that's it so
you look great you look great you know
your hair looks great I'm jealous you
know you got the you got the picture
behind you you know like it's fine
there's so many High produced videos
that
just totally bomb
um I actually thought about making a
video on this picture and this might
resonate with somebody I don't know can
you see the head no I just see the tie
like it cuts off at the time oh yeah
okay I know that one have you ever seen
the movie Thomas Crown Affair with
Pierce Brosnan
oh yes but I don't know that I can
remember the skills the painting that's
in it and that's always been my favorite
painting ever okay and and it's fine you
know just the guy with the Apple in
front of his face and I never could
figure out like why it was so drawn to
me and I had this conversation with my
therapist about a month ago and we were
talking about it
and I said I love it because it's just
the dress the suits like that's just
what I like and I said I always wanted
to bring men's hats back and she was
like what are your thoughts on the Apple
I said you know I'm really not sure
she was did you ever think meeting me
with my issues that the the stuff that
I've dealt with from a mental health
standpoint and you put your images to
cover up your insecurities and
addictions all that shows do you ever
think that that painting represents
putting forward a as perfect of an image
as you think you can
but you're not letting anybody see who
you are on the inside
there you go that like smacked me in the
face so that's why I have that hanging
there
so
anyways I digress but I I share that
with people whenever I can because I'm
sure that will resonate with somebody
that hears that story
and now it's living it
you know like if you're not making
videos because you're worried about
editing and being professional
you're still the Apple guy well I I
guess it's about trying to figure out
how to get the attention to get the
views you know what I mean posting to
post and this and that not not really
getting out there and even from the
YouTube standpoint which it's been a
couple months it's like okay figure out
basic thumbnails no big deal but the
contents and stuff that actually make it
engaging to want people to come back and
I know a lot of that does have to do I
know that I know you're going to say the
content the message is the most
important thing but you know I always
tell people they always say you only get
one chance to make a first impression I
actually disagree there's two because
it's it's what you look like and what
you sound like and if people don't like
what they're seeing they're not going to
stick around long enough to hear what
you have to say or do you get a great
message but have a horrible appearance
and that could turn someone off too so I
kind of felt like well you got to kind
of have them both to a little bit
but not at the expense of not posting
you know like yes the message and the
consistency
you know you you look
great
there's no reason why like if you film
from here just as you are right now
versus having a professional guy come in
and film you
it's like a five percent better to have
the pro come in and film you okay
it's not that it's not as big as we make
it and you're probably going to be a
little worse because you're going to be
more intimidated by the camera and the
lights and like somebody watching you
and that's a skill set that you work on
I mean at least for me it took me a
while to get used to having somebody
behind and feel like I got to deliver
for them and I'm wasting the time and
you know actually I wouldn't bother your
minds more about the appearance when
you're done how to make it look good how
to have the transitions how to how to
have the edits and the intros and the
outs and the let's Evan like what you're
so great at is sharing your
vulnerability
this is your superpower it's like when
somebody this is like I think you
actually create a disconnect for people
is when they look at you you look
perfect you look you got it all figured
out you got this business you're buying
you got the hair you got the shirt you
know it's like it all looks perfect
Meanwhile your whole message is guys I'm
not perfect like I almost killed myself
X years ago right like I was ready to
pull the trigger I was there and and
then that's when you start to be
relatable to people
it doesn't mean now you show up like a
bomb to everything that you're doing
because this is who you you know it's
that's what it's who you are and what
you wear but right
going even fancier
is like how many of the people that you
deal with
ask the people that you who are dming
you hey how much have you reaching out
to me is because I look fancy
it's like zero
right you're creating the block of the
authenticity for you
okay well the stuff in the car is my
favorite
yeah I get so much backlash on that from
people too like stop driving and
videoing well that's that's its own
thing but but in terms of like just how
you show up as the real Evan
That's What Makes You relatable to
people you're not trying to you I've
never at least seen you try to show off
and say look at my thing look at this
um and that's what a lot of over-the-top
production does right like you really
have two models to go you've got you can
do the Grant Cardone style where you
show up in your in your roles and you're
burning money on the roof and like
flinging things off and it's like crazy
high production right or or you just
talk to the camera
right and depending on what you're
trying to accomplish if you're trying to
create a deep meaningful connection with
people and say hey I understand you
that's going to work a lot better
the the the high-end production creates
the aspiration like oh I want to be like
this person someday
but they're unrelatable
we're just talking the camera knowing
what you went through is the thing that
will suck people in and want to work
with you want to take whatever that next
step is
okay it doesn't mean you disrespect
editing and all that forever but it's a
five percent difference like having that
camera guy come in versus you is a five
percent bump on your views
well I wasn't so much concerned about
that kind of professional but more on
the back of it that's all same thing
like the fact you have lower thirds
coming up and some music playing behind
you and your name shows up that you
don't know how to do you don't know how
to put your name I don't know how to put
my name on the bottom of the video like
that stuff doesn't matter barely right
barely it's like extra five percent you
know if you're if you're playing at the
level where you're making daily content
you are consistent you're making some
money from it you can afford to invest
that back into the team then yes that
makes a big difference if you're talking
about your business and what you do and
you're trying to make a a fancy
promotional video or something that's
gonna you're gonna run it on local TV
shows or something
um then sure maybe although I would
still maybe fight against that like I
would love to see your video of you
telling your story
I think that would get you a lot more
business than trying to be fancy
I know I know with your time I have two
quick questions though one I tried to
ask on on movement makers one is um what
I'm reading I think I actually got an
email from flick about number of
hashtags
um using to use less because Moore's
getting suppressed on Instagram but
number two over the last month Instagram
has really started to suppress content
that has users or or
um using
um depression anxiety even a little bit
of addiction because of some people are
making the claim of what social media is
doing to particularly young females and
that you know having the adverse effect
of seeing other people and causing
anxiety and depression so I didn't know
if you heard anything like that because
that actually hurts what I'm trying to
do
um it I just I'm still trying to figure
it out I just didn't know what your
thoughts were yeah uh the best Instagram
strategy right now is community so
anybody who is following you who gives a
thumbs up like what I what I should do
is look at everybody who's joined us
live and then save it and then DM them a
video to say hey thank you Aang and
thadius and Mimi Mimi lines like I
really appreciate you
so it gives them a reason to come back
and follow you Instagram
the hashtags that wouldn't worry so much
about like it's a tiny tiny tiny
difference uh content suppression yes
especially and if you're talking about
alcohol and you know guns and stuff then
that
definitely will happen but Instagram
organic is down for everybody
across the board
um not as many people are using
Instagram and uh
there's a lot more ads ah I don't like I
started put I've been putting some just
just to have some but I haven't really
done much with or gone in on it so I
don't have a great spot to send people
yet you know I have more Tick Tock
followers than I do Instagram
it's easier to win on Tick Tock at least
in terms of getting followers but the
depth isn't there okay you know the
dming isn't there
um you're targeting a really younger
audience still for now so if you that's
if that was who you're going after then
yes okay for most people in thought
leadership it's not a good solution
um so you you still think staying with
YouTube and Instagram is my primary and
keep it that way and then YouTube for
sure for sure but it's a longer game for
YouTube right like you need to stay on
it you need to stay consistent for sure
YouTube has only gone up Instagram for
now is where I would still be
um
I'm getting I'm getting deep into
Discord so I'm a big fan of that yet now
so well that but that's that's more time
like right you gotta you gotta invest
your time I have
I have more XP or more levels on Tom
billu's Discord server than some of his
moderators
because I spent a bunch of time in there
talking to people
um so it's anti-leverage like it doesn't
it doesn't it it disappears as soon as
the conversation is over right like it's
a chat stream that's flowing
for you it's I would still do Instagram
um maybe maybe Tick Tock becomes
something that you could do but there's
no other there's no other place like
Clubhouse could be good for audio only
but again the content doesn't live super
long
um
yeah it's everybody's face in it every
it's why some people from Instagram are
going to YouTube because well I guess my
I guess my primary thing right now isn't
I would like it to become professional
from a business standpoint but I'm not
worried about that like I have a
business like my Chase isn't money in
there so I would like to create
something
a value that if I got hit by a bus
tomorrow well my stuff would still be
out there and maybe help somebody five
years from now and I figure if you do
enough of that well the rest will take
care of itself
well then then you need to listen to
your own advice
you know like if you're thinking about
five years from now then YouTube has to
be the play
but you're not consistent on it because
you didn't get enough results like on
the last video or the last five videos
like if you're actually if you can
actually remember hey I'm making this
for where I'm going to be in five years
because the stuff you talk about is
still going to be a problem in five
years unfortunately right like well I do
I used to think I wanted this to replace
what I'm currently doing coven made me
get a new appreciation for my business
because it's very residual and then my
content led me to a really big deal so
I've kind of refocused like all right
well this is game changer life change
kind of thing so
now it's I don't say it's a passion
project but I feel like well now I can
do it right
and I want to do it right in a non not a
non-frustrating kind of way but it has
shifted like I've gone back and forth
like four times so where I'm at now what
I thought I wanted to do brought me the
opportunity to make what I didn't think
I wanted to do even bigger so like I
can't ignore that so it's kind of you
know great so if if you don't need it to
pay off right away right then what you
invest in is not the professionalism you
invest in whatever the thing is that
makes it more convenient for you and
more fun for you right because if you're
making daily content for the next five
years holy cow with your heart and your
message you will you will build
something that could rival your current
business and then you have the luxury to
pick which one you want to do so what
roadblocks are in the way of you having
fun making content
it's not it's not professionalism and
lower thirds and editing like what do
you need that hey your Jazz to show up
today and again you have a certain
amount of time you know like I've got
this amount of time every week to make
content and what do I need around me if
I'm if I don't care about it paying off
right away what do I need around me so
it's fine for me to show up and I'm
proud of what we create right okay
if you did that every day for five years
you will have something that will rival
your current business
okay and then you pick I mean you can
have you keep doing both you can pick
you can hand one off to somebody else I
mean it's
well we're gonna we're gonna flip this
one so
there you go yeah now that that's a game
plan so I guess I'll end with this
looking at the time there's no way
Angela or anybody else was going to get
that nft of yours for the simple fact
that one it was on depression so I had
to get it but two your thing with the
closet if you look at mine it is color
coordinated and I actually I use a
little spacer like I'm not kidding I use
a little spacer between all my because I
don't like my shirts to touch in a
closet like I'm real OCD about that so
it was like that was the doesn't matter
I'll never sell I'll never do anything
with it but it's like that was like the
perfect one because depressing is my
topic and the OCD in it is just like you
couldn't have had a better one well I
saw him like I have to get this I love
it we came and we took a picture of your
closet and then we turned it into the
nft yeah that's about it
I'm having a problem with execution
okay
um
I have a problem with trusting there's
so many people reaching out on internet
crypto and with this and with that and
um having issued a lot of people are
doing startups and and have
claims of leadership or claims of you
know
um
and sorry that's my service dog she's
playing with batteries
nice I have a service dog uh
my question to you is like when you have
an idea when you when you're Brewing
something up and you've you've you've
talked to a few people about it
um
what's your first step into scouting out
uh how you're going to execute
uh I worry very little about how I'm
going to execute I just go do something
I think when you get an idea
um sometimes telling your friends is the
right move and sometimes it's not you
know sometimes your friends just poke
holes in it and tell you why it sucks uh
and
doesn't help because it's just an idea
of course there's tons of holes in it
you know like you don't know what you're
doing
at the start
and so
people over think the first step and
overthink the how
where the how really just you got to
start doing something what's something
that you're
struggling on how to get started uh
Trust
trust with trust with who trust with my
ideas
um Okay Okay I uh I went to lock down
the idea with some lawyers and stuff and
they were from the uh us and things were
a little bit different here
um I don't wanna
fear of having fear I guess
you know uh fear of putting myself out
there and
it's a really great idea and it would
help a lot of people I'm I I am built to
serve
totally built to serve I do not do
anything if it's not I ask myself okay
if I'm gonna do this action who is it
helping why am I doing that
because they're off the passion Fizzles
out right so it's got to be lined up
with my value system with my family with
the life I want for myself and
um
so yeah built a third but I I'm having
trust issues with trusting people with
my idea that would take advantage of it
and only see the dollar sign to not be
and not the service of it
to people who need it yeah so you're
worried about sharing your idea with the
wrong people yes and then what but
they're going to run with your idea and
and leave you in the dust
maybe I don't know because I mean I'm
new at this right it's gonna happen like
it's gonna happen I'm gonna I've been I
followed Bethany Frankel a lot I love
her a lot and I love her the work that
she does especially uh with the relief
stuff I follow people who give back you
know I'm not in it for the money I'm
finished to help
um okay but so what's the worst case
scenario for you like you're going to
tell somebody
your idea and it's the wrong person
who's not service driven and just doing
money signs what what's in your head as
I like what's the worst case scenario
for you what are you so afraid of
in a wrong way
that they that they use you in the wrong
way
that they would use I don't know and cut
you out or what like they're working
with them and they screw you over or
they just cut you out and do it on their
own or what what are you super concerned
about
I don't know but I'd have no input in
the in the long run that they would take
it and of course have more funds or
something like that to solidify how they
want to do it my dog is eating Clips
right now I gotta get up
Sebastian
I know Xena
come on Xena the Warrior Princess
I've had her for about three weeks she's
a rescue uh that was given to me by
Wounded Warriors Canada and trained uh
for my PTSD and I guess she's feeling my
nervousness maybe that's great hey she's
a good service dog she is
the idea
is your idea and it's birth from your
heart and nobody will be able to run
your idea the way that you can run the
idea
so when people tell me every every day
almost somebody is messaging me to say
hey Evan this person is taking your idea
somebody else is doing a top 10 rules
for success or whatever
okay I mean I spend zero time thinking
about that because if all you're doing
is being an Evan Chronicle copycat
you're never gonna you're never gonna
ultimately win like being an Elvis
impersonator is a business model but
it's better for you to go and create
your own art instead of just trying to
be somebody else right so Elvis isn't
worried about I mean Elvis isn't alive
yeah it's like you don't worry about the
people
so so if your idea
people are so concerned about giving up
their idea it's like but the idea
without you isn't an idea like the idea
alone isn't enough it's the heart behind
it yeah and I realize it takes a lot of
um
of consistency and effort and structure
to to run an idea to fruition to
actually implement it and and you know
it's it's like a baby right it's the
first 10 years or five years or or
whatever and I'm a veteran that has PTSD
and some other you know physical issues
um due to service and I'm just
what if I can't uh when what if I can't
run you know what if I fall because I
have a tendency to
invest and then I'm passionate about it
and then
I'm I'm tired and I'm broken and I'm you
know the balance isn't quite there yet
well you're gonna fall
yeah
it's like how many times did you run a
drill and fall
yeah and then what did you do
get back up when you keep running right
I mean you're you're the key is that the
Falls are just micro Falls not a macro
fall right and that
yeah well you just how do you get back
up you you plant one foot in front of
the other and you push yourself back up
and you go finish the course
yeah right okay finish the mission you
finish the like there's there's nothing
that will be fatal as long as you still
love the mission that you're on
is to help people actually you know it's
to happen I feel it of
um
to be able to engage themselves like you
know people tend to over push in in
workouts and not be aligned and their
hips are not aligned when they're doing
certain positions and stuff so uh it's
to help people since since covid a lot
of people are been have been training at
home and um a lot of injuries can happen
when you're training on your own
so and so that's the thing it's like
okay you might hurt yourself and if you
do that it doesn't mean never work out
again it means maybe one one we need to
go slower
and two we need to actually learn some
technique so that we're not hurting
ourselves this happened to me so like
I'm doing yoga
three times a week three to four times a
week every two days so some days it's
three so sometimes it's three some weeks
is four and I tried yoga like a decade
ago or maybe eight years ago from a
YouTube video and just pulled every
muscle in my body like it just the next
day was I and if it wasn't yoga it was
me I'm doing I think I'm doing it right
because I'm watching video but obviously
I did a whole bunch wrong because I was
in pain and not the good pain like a
good workout pain just like oh my gosh
this is this is terrible pain and I just
wrote off yoga you know and so that's a
mistake like the problem isn't yoga the
problem is
me I didn't learn it properly I need I
need better instruction I need guidance
so so we you know hired a bunch of
instructors who Now teach us my wife and
I every two days how to do yoga and it's
so much better
so the the message is to keep going
right I mean it doesn't mean that
working out isn't for you of course if
you want to live a long healthy life you
have to learn to take care of your body
and you have to work out but but it
doesn't mean push yourself like a maniac
and it doesn't mean hurt yourself right
there's better ways to do it
so if you take that analogy for your
business and your idea it's the same
thing it's like you you need to not stop
yourself like you're throwing up all of
these hurdles in front of your own
business and your idea
which is me not doing yoga for eight
years you know you can't wait eight
years for you to launch this thing
because people need it yeah right
and you will fall and you will make
mistakes and it won't be perfect and
some some people may not be the best for
you and you may talk to a potential
business partner who doesn't have the
right interest right I mean you just
have to trust that your heart will guide
you to the right decisions like you
decided to ask to come on live here
right you know that that wasn't me like
picking on you you said pick me I want
to come alive I was all set I was all
set stuff and and
um there's so many times that I go on
here and I was like I wish I could ask
him some questions
um my other question about balance about
balance you have a wife you have a child
um and you have a bunch of ideas like
I'm a really creative person I was an
F-18 technician for years for 24 years I
was fixing Jets so I had to
sometimes do repairs that were
unconventional and needed some
imagination uh what I'm finding is as
I'm moving forward and opening up my
creativity I have a bunch of ideas how
do you select which one or do you just
push three at the same time or focus on
the one uh bring that one to fluorition
and then move on to the next
it's the same answer
as the first question you're asking how
questions right it's like you do it okay
what's the smallest possible way to get
started and then you do it and the key
to figure out is what
makes you come alive the most
because in your three ideas what you
could do you've got three ideas for
Vicky 2021 perfect
you could research and plan and
strategize and and watch videos and read
books and attend seminars for the rest
of the year and still not have taken any
action on it and no matter how many
conversations you have with me or
friends or whoever I can't tell you
which idea you should do right like they
could all be I'm sure they're all great
ideas just trust it because it came to
you it's a good idea period like the
fact that it came to you as long as it
has good intention like it's my
intention to serve as my attention to
help it's my intention to do good yes
great it's then it's a good idea
until you start actually doing it you
won't know until if it's a if it feels
right and something you want to commit
the next five years of your life to
doing
right
so whatever the smallest possible thing
that you could do on any of those ideas
that's how you should start okay
like what could you do today on that
idea that feels insignificant and Tiny
and small and like not not a big step at
all
that's the step okay so if somebody
wanted to become like if somebody wants
to get into the Air Force and be a
mechanic that's a long process
right that's not just something you just
do tomorrow
I do a lot
for especially youth because they don't
know what they're getting into or how to
Yum so there's a
I haven't but if that's like if that's
somebody's dream right potentially then
what's the best thing you can do today
well go try to visit an air base
yeah
and just
just be on the base and how does it make
you feel does it make you feel like wow
this is this is epic like I want to be
here or does it feel like oh this
actually doesn't feel like what I
thought it was going to feel like
because no matter how much you read
about it or watch videos about it or
anything else like you just won't know
until you start actually doing it right
um I'll use the example thinking through
Sushi like how do you know if you like
sushi
well you don't know until you you put it
in your mouth because it sounds gross
it's raw fish and seaweed and rice and
hot mustard and soy sauce and that's
going to be good it sounds nasty but
then you eat it's like oh my God this is
amazing or some people might think it
still is nasty whatever but you you
don't know until you actually just put
it in your mouth and you see
if it tastes good yeah and that's what
you need to do with your ideas you need
to put it in your mouth and eat it and
see if it tastes good yeah and if it
tastes good you go back and you keep you
keep doing it and you'll get better at
it and you develop the skill sets you
know like if you can fix a Jet Plane you
could you could fix anything
says so he doesn't call anyone he he
lies on wifey
[Laughter]
so you could figure anything out
but
in the if you just over researching
overthinking over planning over asking
instead of just tasting it and
don't worry if the first step sucks it's
gonna suck but you just try it and you
see how does it make you feel the
self-confidence thing and the the
perfectionism uh of my past trade you
know that's lingering if you
if you're not going to do it right the
first time don't do it at all which was
that but I'm trying to move out of that
mindset and say try everything fail at
everything but feel forward
sure but you know it's like now speeding
that up because
your two questions about how do I do
this if it doesn't matter you just got
to do do something like the thing
and I get and you know I've helped a
bunch of people through military to
entrepreneurship transition and like
highly highly highly structured to told
exactly what to do all the time like
saps the creativity and now you're like
oh my God I'm on my own what do I do uh
I don't have my friends anymore there's
no Community anymore I'm by myself how
do I come back to you know normal life
especially if you've been in combat and
just
anyway
um
the thing to keep from it is it's not
like throw the whole thing away the
thing to keep is the discipline
and that something has to happen today
yeah right
the thing that you want to step into is
the creativity and the love and the
service all that is great but something
has to happen today and the discipline
that I'm going to show up and the mental
toughness to show up and do it
even when you don't know how like if you
were if you were to tell your commanding
officer I don't know about the I have
imposter syndrome I don't know if I can
do this or not because what are you
talking Vicky do it oh no we don't
[Music]
so we need a little bit of that you know
back to show yourself to and remind
yourself what a badass you are
and that you'll figure it out
I am badass thank you
well it's just remembering that because
that's the only thing that's missing
it's not like how to wipe it's just
I'm a badass my heart is good this is
for service this is to help other people
it's a long start
system
yeah
you cut out for a second I didn't hear
that part and it's in alignment with my
value system and you know yeah
thank you for that
today are you in Toronto where are you
Canadian
um in Ottawa okay close enough so listen
it's 2 30 almost
take today's goal is how do I take a
microaction on all three of my ideas
I already did
yes I have I love it uh we were talking
earlier on you were mentioning you know
how to train and you know you do over
stress your body your first session at
yoga well I'm a little bit you know
great like white or black and I tend to
over train as well if I'm gonna go for a
short run I might end up for a two hour
run you know depends on how I feel so I
have a kinesiologist
and so I did discuss my ideas with a
kinesiologist show her the project and
we're gonna act on that and then I need
to call the chiropractor so she can put
her little two cents on the project so
when I do go uh forward then it's not
it's solidified by a kinesiologist and a
chiropractor
yeah I mean having experts to help you
and and if you know that you go crazy
having some people sometimes you need
somebody to put the brakes on a little
bit too well kinesiologist is there for
uh I have a kinesiologist twice a week
and she doesn't allow me to do push-ups
or sit-ups or anything like that she
goes no your muscles your you know your
injuries they're too you need to build
muscle before you go back to what you
were doing before
so and she sets the brakes on me my
husband does too he says okay you've
been doing enough go sit down or you
know
um I tend to go over
and push myself
past my physical limits
and mental limits and
yeah learning how to respect
my body and my and everything else in my
family life
um is certainly a balancing act after
serving for 24 years where you're either
really on or really off you know
yeah
well thank you for that
you got it
much appreciated yeah send it send you
less love and and when you feel doubt
and you feel insecurity the two things
to think about are one that you are a
badass and what you've come through and
what you've done that this thing is the
thing that's holding you back compared
to what you've been through like this
little thing compared to what you've
done really right like just that's what
I tell myself too it's like I broke my
neck in 2019 and kept going on my tour
and like making a video is a thing
that's causing me what right just to
remind yourself of how badass you are
and then two the service it's like hey
every every day that you are in your
head thinking about this idea instead of
actually releasing it I'm not certain
you're not serving people and and
somebody's being hurt
because they're not following a method
that you can help them with and
for what because you're overthinking
this thing now that people now people
aren't getting the help they need
because you're up in your head right so
that's that's the little more like oh my
God come on Vicky what are we doing here
right like sometimes you need more of
the the push to be like man buck up and
get this thing done because people need
you and sometimes you need more of the
the pot on the back it's like I've been
through way worse than this right so
like whatever you're feeling more either
the pat on the back or like the push to
go forward
are the easiest ways to get out of your
head and into action mode yeah
okay well thank you I'll leave either
office but I'm going to continue I want
to leave the space for others as well
thank you so much for uh letting me join
this live and I love your content and
you encourage me every day
uh just wonder appreciate you Vicky and
and listen thank you for putting up your
hand
because
not everybody does and uh I wasn't even
gonna bring somebody in but I don't know
I saw your face like okay you know what
let's bring in Vicky all right much love
thank you Vicky much love take care okay
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you were starting today right
now and you were to launch into the
thought leadership business and your
goal was to get to twenty thousand
dollars a month in Revenue what you
would do for yourself if you were
getting back into it uh and you were
willing and you're willing to take
massive and Extreme Action